intitulé des fleurs ou des pavés c'était
donc le troisième volet de la série ni
dieu ni maître une histoire de
l'anarchisme écrit et réalisée par
Tancré de ramonais le quatrième et
dernier volet de cette série fera
l'objet d'un autre débat docle
l'occasion maintenant de s'interroger
sur ce plateau avec nos invités sur le
poids et l'influence coru jusqu'ici
l'anarchisme sur notre société avec vous
pour commencer Édouard Jourdain
bienvenue vous êtes chercheur en théorie
politique spécialiste de la pensée
anarchiste votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule géopolitique de l'anarchisme
vers un nouveau moment libertaire il a
été publié aux éditions Le Cavalier Bleu
et puis on suscitera également en lien
avec cette émission l'anarchisme publié
cette fois c'est la découverte Sylvain
Boulou qui est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes historien
spécialiste de l'anarchiste et du
communisme et votre dernier livre
s'intitule lui le peuple du drapeau noir
une histoire des anarchistes ouvrages
publiés aux éditions Atlantes et puis
enfin avec nous Christophe Bourseiller
bienvenue à vous vous êtes tout à la
fois historien auteur avec entre autres
plusieurs essais consacrés au courant
extrémiste et minoritaire dont celui-ci
nouvelle histoire de l'ultra gauche
publié aux éditions du Cerf après avoir
vu ce troisième volet de cette fresque
historique écrite et réalisée par
Tancrède Ramonet il nous manque bien
entendu le premier et le deuxième volet
de cette fresque historique d'où un
certain besoin d'un cours de rattrapage
si on peut dire les choses comme ça en
commençant par peut-être tout simplement
par la définition que donne le Larousse
de l'anarchisme je la cite conception
politique et sociale qui se fonde sur le
rejet de toute tutelle gouvernementale
administrative religieuse et qui
privilégie la liberté et l'initiative
individuelle d'où évidemment cette
fameuse devise ni Dieu ni maître et
alors vous prévenez hein d'emblée dans
votre ouvrage l'anarchisme l'anarchisme
est encore aujourd'hui mal compris
souvent considéré comme une doctrine
prenant le désordre et le chaos ou toute
vie politique serait impossible alors
expliquez-nous c'est quoi l'anarchisme
c'est une grande question parce que
c'est une
plus qu'une idéologie d'ailleurs c'est
un corpus d'idée qui est très riche dans
l'histoire des idées je pense qu'il y a
peut-être le libéralisme aussi qui est
aussi riche que l'anarchisme en réalité
il y a il y a plusieurs plusieurs
doctrines plusieurs idées qu'on va
pouvoir y rattacher de manière très
simple en effet il y a ce rejet de
l'État mais qui n'est pas un rejet de
l'ordre il faut bien distinguer les deux
il y a cette idée que on peut constituer
une société libre autonome et en même
temps relativement ordonné ce qu'on dit
pas le Larousse dans sa définition c'est
que en règle générale aussi il y a une
critique radicale du capitalisme et il
faut bien resituer aussi la naissance de
de en tant que corpus de
doctrine d'idées ça arrive au début du
19e siècle avec la consolidation de
l'État moderne mais aussi l'émergence de
la question sociale la question ouvrière
plus particulièrement et ce qu'on va
considérer comme le père ou le premier
théoricien de l'anarchisme qui est
Pierre-Joseph Proudhon vient précisément
de cette classe ouvrière lui-même les
paysans il a été aussi artisan et ça va
être le premier à se réclamer au sens
positif du terme anarchiste dans son
célèbre mémoire qu'est-ce que la
propriété auxquels il répondra c'est le
vol qui est cette formule souvent qu'on
a d'ailleurs gardé souvent d'ailleurs
aussi très mal comprise mais c'est dans
cet ouvrage qu'il affirmera qu'il est
possible en réalité de concevoir une
société
libre et mon cipé constitué d'individus
qui créent eux-mêmes leur règle sans
qu'il y ait un état qui le leur impose
avec une possibilité
aussi de socialiser les moyens de
production etc alors après il a aussi
toute une théorie du fédéralisme qui va
irriguer l'ensemble des des autres
doctrines anarchistes mais c'est sans
doute lui qui va être le point nodal en
termes théorique en tout cas le premier
vraiment à leoriser et là nous sommes au
milieu du 19e siècle alors on distingue
originellement l'anarchisme socialiste
Proudhon l'anarchisme individualiste
sterner qui est un Allemand et puis un
anarchiste communiste Bakounine voilà ça
c'est est-ce que
originellement on a là les les trois
figures majeures de ce que on pourrait
même rendre laquelle on peut commencer à
parler de l'anarchisme on pourrait même
rajouter une quatrième qui est le
syndicalisme ce qui donnera par la suite
la narcos syndicalisme effectivement on
a le panel de ce que peut-être
l'anarchiste ce qui veut dire que
d'après après après ce qu'on vient de
dire il y a pratiquement autant
d'anarchismes que d'anarchistes puisque
chacun peut puiser dans ce corpus de
pénal qui pas de Proudhon à Bakounine un
peu l'outil pour les syndicalistes dans
les éléments qui m'intéressent et se
faire sa propre représentation et sa
propre idée de l'anarchisme philosophie
qui repose alors sur trois Antilles
principaux lentilles étatisme
l'Anticapitaliste une autre dimension
est importante qui est la capitalisme
Bakounine par exemple écrire un livre
qui s'appelle Dieu l'état même si les
publier à titre posthume qui s'appelle
Dieu et l'état dans lequel il condamne
la religion et puis on ajoutera au fur
et à mesure du temps l'anticommunisme
qui va donner alors c'est amusant les
anarchistes se sont dit comme une liste
mais l'antibolchimisme si on préfère qui
va devenir une les autres colères avoir
plusieurs colonnes vertébrales peut-être
un peu compliqué une autre vertèbre de
l'anarchisme c'est-à-dire qui se définit
par des Antibes mais qui se définit
aussi par des des pour c'est à dire
comment créer une société
d'individus libre alors ça peut passer
par justement les groupes de travail qui
peuvent représenter le syndicalisme des
individus qui se rassemblent dans des
communautés qui va plutôt être la
modalité que vont retrouver des anarchos
individualistes ou alors une dimension
insurrectionnelle plutôt de
et collectif qu'on va retrouver plutôt
dans le communisme libertaire ou
l'anarchisme communiste théorisé par
Bakounine puis par competine son
principe son premier disciple on va dire
alors ça c'est pour la le 19e siècle au
20e siècle à une constellation
d'anarchistes finalement c'est très
difficile en réalité tu vois assez clair
pour les néophytes qui ne connaissent
pas grand chose à l'anarchisme mais
c'est la nature même de ce qu'est
l'anarchie je veux justement oui il y a
une certaine impression sémantique du
terme anarchiste c'est-à-dire que il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui peut vous dire je
suis un tout petit peu hanar et on sait
pas très bien ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire je fais ce que je veux je suis
individualiste au 15 il y a 7 ambiguïté
par ailleurs sur la base du tronc que
composé nos deux amis on pourrait dire
qu'il y a aussi une part société de
l'anarchiste qui est très importante et
qui pas vraiment fleurir au début du 20e
siècle c'est notamment la libération de
la femme qui va se faire dans des
groupes anarchistes il y a plein de
femmes qui vont apparaître ça va être
également le végétarisme c'est-à-dire la
naissance du bio toute une forme
d'écologie qui va apparaître et puis
alors la défense de l'homosexualité qui
est totalement tabou au début du 20e
siècle à la fin du 19e mais on va voir
apparaître l'idée de la camaraderie
amoureuse chez un individualisme qui
s'appelle Emile Armand par exemple et
alors c'est évidemment parfois une une
camarade réamoureuse qui va être on
pourrait dire sans entrave et qui
parfois va verser dans la pédophilie
donc il va être parfois plus plus
inquiétante on pourrait dire mais enfin
il y a aussi cette idée là donc vous
voyez ce qui est assez curieux et très
frappant dans l'anarchisme c'est aussi
cette dimension culturelle dès le départ
qui fait que de très nombreux artistes
vont s'agréger à la mouvance anarchie
vous savez il y a la fameuse chanson de
Léo Ferré il y en 1% et pourtant ils
existent vous voyez c'est une chanson
dans laquelle Léo Ferré lui-même se
réclamait de l'anarchisme et Léo Ferré
explique en quoi il se relie à ça et
vous allez avoir au fil du 20e siècle
des personnalités très diverses comme
Albert Camus Léo Ferré justement
beaucoup d'autres qui vont s'agréger à
cette à cette idée anarchiste et c'est
très curieux par exemple je j'entendais
il y a pas très longtemps un interview
de Pierre Berger qui expliquait que dans
son jeune âge il avait démarré à la
Fédération anarchiste vous voyez ce
voyez le parcours qu'on peut avoir mais
c'est ça on dit long sur cet espèce de
très large socle culturel qui était
l'anarchie anarchisme politique et
l'anarchisme culturel alors on va
revenir à celui que vous avez cité tout
à l'heure qui finalement le premier
théoricien de l'anarchisme qui est
français qui qui est Pierre Joseph
Proudhon avec le mutualisme qui
s'associe très vite à à son nom et puis
une expérience pour donian où en grande
partie prunogene qui est la commune
1871 les 72 jours de la commune là c'est
la mise en oeuvre pratique
en grande partie de ces théories
autogestion fédéralisme
ça c'est la première mise en œuvre
pratique alors qui est l'anarchisme
alors qui est évidemment à nuance c'est
parce qu'en réalité dans la Commune de
Paris on a plusieurs courants
idéologiques très différents alors il y
a une partie en effet qui se réclame de
Proudhon on a des des personnes
importantes comme comme Jules Vallès
taulent etc bon il va y avoir en effet
en tout cas un esprit prudognant de la
commune avec en effet des formes
d'autogestion d'assemblées il y a la
question sociale évidemment qui est très
très intégrée dans la commune il y a
aussi cette idée
alors qui est qui est débattu y compris
au sein de la commune
de fédéralisme des villes des communes
françaises il y a d'ailleurs une un
essai aussi à Lyon dans sur action de la
commune où se trouve
Bakounine d'ailleurs mais qui va
lamentablement périclité mais il y a des
tensions aussi au sein de la commune où
il y en a qui sont plus
comment dire plus pour une forme de
dictature avec l'instauration en vue
d'un Comité de salut public etc contre
contre lequel certains d'ailleurs
proudhoniens vont s'insurger en disant
bah non il faut surtout pas reconduire
une forme de de dictature donc on a
cette
ambivalence cet essai en tout cas qui
politique qui va être en effet largement
inspiré de d'une d'un esprit proudien
alors à tel point d'ailleurs que que ces
ennemis de l'époque déjà qui se dessine
qui vont être les
marxistes donc à l'époque il y a Marx
qui va écrire sur sur la commune puis
Engels etc et on a déjà assisté à la
rupture entre Proudhon et alors il y a
déjà une 1846 exactement mais qui va
être confirmé là aussi par l'épisode de
la Commune de Paris à tel point même que
Engels va dire la fin de la Commune de
Paris sonne le glas du protonisme donc
en quelque sorte c'est ça va être la
victoire des idées allemandes du
socialisme dit autoritaire contre le
socialisme libertaire qui aurait qui
aurait failli avec la le massacre de la
Commune de Paris en quelque sorte alors
prudo il a il aura fait école au sein
notamment du Parti socialiste
anciennement et ses chiots et puis le
Parti socialiste de François Mitterrand
Jaurès voulait s'inspirer en partie de
la doctrine
Proudhon à l'histoire du socialisme que
et un peu de l'anarchisme aussi puisque
un certain nombre de fondateurs ou de
grands animateurs du mouvement
socialiste à la fin du 19e siècle son
inspiration proudonienne et c'est une
c'est l'histoire d'une onde conversion
marxisme Paul Brousse et quelques autres
même Juliette qui est passé par le
mouvement liberté un moment c'est une
longue conversion et puis ils ensemble
aboutir à des
visions de déchets de des théories
libertaires enfin ils définissent la
théorie se rendre compte que pour eux ça
ne marche pas et donc il évoluent vers
des formes de politiques carboc qui ne
sont pas en phase avec l'anarchisme par
exemple ils vont commencer à se
présenter aux élections ce qui pour les
libertaires est totalement incongru donc
vous avez cette évolution lente mais qui
envoie plus à l'histoire du socialisme
français l'histoire l'anarchisme même
s'il est deux peuvent être enchevêtrés
et effectivement tout au long de la fin
du 19e siècle et du début du 20e siècle
vous avez des formes se rapprochement on
peut prendre une autre figure qui est
Léon Blum Léon Blum participent dans son
jeune temps à la Revue Blanche où on
retrouve un anarchiste le premier de
refusa anarchiste qui est Bernard lézard
où on retrouve Félix fainéon un artiste
anarchiste donc il y a une porosité qui
existe qui est très très forte entre les
deux on pourrait même poursuivre
jusqu'au psud de Michel Rocard et on
peut et la deuxième gauche notamment sur
l'idée de l'autogestion qui a été une
ligne forte effectivement même si l'idée
de l'autogestion c'est quand même un
modèle au départ qui vient de la
Yougoslavie qui est adapté par la CFDT
qui est en voie de décrétisation à ce
moment-là et la question de
l'autogestion mériterait même un débat
parce que c'était des
usines Yougoslavie qui était quand même
qui restaient sous contrôle du PC
yougoslave les Français ont fait des
visites là-bas ils sont rendu compte
qu'il était peut-être possible d'un
extraire un modèle les libertaires à ce
moment-là préfèrent l'idée de gestion
direct de l'entreprise par l'ensemble
des donc il y a deux choses qui sont
deux modèles qui sont proches où on a
effectivement des idées communes et mais
en même temps avec des séparations qui
existent qui font que les on a quand
même deux arbres différents dont les
feuilles peuvent s'entremêler la commune
terrain
expérimental
très forte entre les marxistes et les
anarchistes qui est fondamentales et qui
va durer jusque dans les années on
pourrait dire 1960 où il arrive à
apparaître des personnages clés alors
dans les années 1950 Georges Fontenis
dans les années 1960 Daniel Guérin qui
vont
oser faire ce que les anarchistes
n'avaient pas fait pendant près d'un
siècle c'est-à-dire oser une synthèse
entre le marxisme et l'anarchisme et là
pendant qu'il faut bien imaginer que de
1871 en gros jusqu'en 1965 à peu près
les anarchistes sont des ennemis mortels
du marxisme et des ennemis mortels du
bolcheviste du léninisme et il va y
avoir à partir de Daniel enfin une un
nouveau courant qui va apparaître et là
il faut insister sur un personnage clé
qui n'est pas Proudhon qui est michel
Bakounine parce que michel Bakounine
c'est l'inventeur du communisme
libertaire donc c'est un une branche de
l'anarchiste qui reconnaît la lutte des
classes et qui divergent avec Mars
principalement sur le processus
c'est-à-dire que mars il a théorisé tout
un processus scientifique pour aller
vers la révolution alors que Bakounine
dit il faut allumer l'incendie ça va se
déclencher tout de suite et le
prolétariat va prendre les armes et va
prendre le pouvoir immédiatement et
instaurer une société fédérale
horizontale et donc ils à partir de
l'axe les lignes vont bouger parce qu'il
y a toute une nouvelle génération qui va
arriver qui va dire finalement Marx
Bakounine on peut faire la synthèse des
deux et ça va donner lieu à toute une
effervescence et Daniel Cohn-Bendit fait
partie d'un groupe qui s'appelle noir et
rouge et noir et rouge c'est un groupe
comme son nom l'indique alors c'est un
il fait allusion au drapeau du
communisme libertaire qui promenait de
l'Espagne républicaine mais en même
temps c'est vraiment l'idée de faire la
synthèse entre le drapeau rouge
communiste et le drapeau noir de
l'anarchisme donc là il y a un truc
nouveau on va redire un mot bien entendu
de Daniel Cohn-Bendit tout il a
évidemment des questions dans ce
troisième volet de cette fresque
historique que nous venons de voir à
l'instant retour à l'instant sur la
guerre d'Espagne vous l'avez évoqué elle
est également évoquée dans ce
documentaire parce que là les
anarchistes y prendront toute leur place
oui alors l'épisode de la guerre civile
espagnole en effet est fondamental
centrale c'est sans doute le l'épisode
le plus important dans dans l'histoire
anarchiste puisque
il faut bien avoir en tête que
après la révolution russe le Parti
communiste espagnol ne s'aligne pas sur
le Kremlin et c'est un des rares en
Europe et du coup les les marxis les
communistes ne vont pas du tout prendre
corps dans le en Espagne et ça va être
principalement en réalité les
anarchistes donc dans les milieux des
années 30 on a plus plus d'un million
d'A à la Fédération anarchiste
ibérique et à peu près autant pour la
Confédération nationale du travail ce
qui est une force colossale et donc au
coup d'État de Franco en
1936 il commence à y avoir la
désaffrontements très violents et bien
il va y avoir aussi une insurrection des
anarchistes qui ont alors il y a toute
une polémique d'ailleurs parce que ils
ont voté pour le Front populaire qui
leur a promis en retour de libérer les
prisonniers politiques etc mais là aussi
exceptionnellement ils avaient appris à
voter les libertaires on va retrouver
certains ministres anarchistes au
gouvernement même etc mais bon il va y
avoir un soulèvement dans beaucoup de
régions en Espagne principalement en
Catalogne dans les Asturies etc avec
plusieurs collectivités qui vont
fonctionner selon les les principes
anarchistes alors ils vont les voter en
au début de la guerre civile pour
fonctionner selon les principes de de la
narco communisme de selon ses capacités
à chacun selon ses besoins selon les
théories de kropotines notamment mais ça
va avoir une ça va être un flot immense
de de pratiques anarchiste et on
retrouve même à Barcelone des des
drapeaux noirs et rouges des drapeaux
noirs dans la rue avec une un engouement
extrême où on parle de
bref été de la
narcérations espagnols parce que sinon
les communistes espagnoles eux vont leur
faire payer très cher alors l'engagement
dans cette oui en fait c'est que les
communistes espagnoles qui étaient très
minoritaires au début de la guerre
civile vont bénéficier de l'appui
militaire et des conseillers soviétiques
qui vont progressivement infiltrer
l'appareil d'État et l'appareil
répressif de de l'État républicain et
font au fur et à mesure prendre le
contrôle de de l'ensemble des structures
étatiques et utiliser ces structures
étatiques pour réprimer alors d'abord il
y a des groupes communistes dissident
qui s'appelle le Parti ouvrier
d'unification de marxiste dans leader
andrésni sera assassiné et pour réprimer
un certain nombre d'anarchistes avec
deux figures qui sont particulièrement
connues qui sont les anarchistes
italiens qui a milieu bernieri et
qui vont être assassinés par le Sim donc
c'est le service militaire
d'investissement un très sévère échec et
pour les anarchistes alors que la guerre
civile espagnole avait soulevé un espoir
d'une révolution sociale à la fois
paysanne et à la pauvrir puisque toutes
les usines de la Catalogne et d'une
partie de l'Espagne était occupée et
plus ou moins
fonctionnait plus ou moins selon les
principes libertaires effectivement ça
va être une désillusion absolue pour les
libertés espagnoles d'abord et pour les
libertaires du monde entier qui vont
voir le deuxième échec après l'échec de
ce qui avait pu exister en Russie avec
Nestor mcno et la commune de crumstatt
notamment et donc vous pouvez voir le
deuxième échec de anarchiste en voyant
que l'utopie pratique qui était mise en
œuvre finalement
a été détruite alors pas uniquement par
les troupes de Staline aussi par Franco
qui gagne la guerre civile espagnole
mais c'est la conjugaison des normes
divisions dans le mouvement anarchiste
c'est-à-dire que beaucoup d'anarchistes
ne comprennent pas qu'il puisse y avoir
des ministres anarchistes donc il va y
avoir une scission très grave entre la
faille la Fédération anarchistes
ibérique et la CNT qui a envoyé des
ministres au gouvernement et ça c'est un
vrai débat c'est-à-dire c'est le
problème de l'anarchisme c'est est-ce
qu'on peut participer à un gouvernement
si on était anarchiste non alors vous
faisiez référence à 68 et le
documentaire que nous avons vu ce
troisième volet de cette fresque il fait
référence bien entendu Daniel
Cohn-Bendit était un anarchiste Georges
Marchais l'appelait l'anarchiste
allemande d'ailleurs oui oui mais il y
avait pas que Daniel Cohn-Bendit enfin
il était entouré de tout un groupe
d'anarchistes ce qui est un peu triste
mais 68 c'est que ce sont des
libertaires qui ont allumé l'incendie
mais ce sont un groupe gauchiste
léninistes on pourrait dire trop de ski
c'était Maoris qui ont récupéré le en
fait le phénomène parce qu'au départ
vous avez effectivement Daniel
Cohn-Bendit vous avez aussi Jean-Pierre
Duteil qui est à des fondateurs du
mouvement du 22 mars et puis il y a tout
un groupe dont leur là le documentaire
parle pas ou très peu et c'est bien
dommage c'est les situationsistes qui
jouent le rôle véritablement fondamental
de réflexion ils annoncent mais 68 il
pense mais 68 et slogans qui sont peints
sur les murs de Paris et d'ailleurs
vivre sans temps mort jouir sans entrave
et j'en oublie sont des slogans
situationnistes et tous ces gens-là René
Riesel le groupe des enragés de Nanterre
ce sont ceux qui vont allumer l'incendie
de Mai 68 simplement les groupes très
organisés qui font du pratique le
noyotage maoïste et trots vont récupérer
le mouvement de sorte que comme bendy va
être tout seul à gesticuler avec talent
et puis les autres vont être mis de côté
Miss ou boisseau oublier et cette
cette révolution entre guillemets valeur
échapper alors sur 68 je pense qu'il
faut rajouter deux ou trois autres
choses dans les origines de 68 un
champion dans ce documentaire que nous
venons de voir vous êtes d'accord avec
la lecture qui en est faite par Tancré
de ramonais mais très peut-être
rapidement
c'est justement ces origines culturelles
qu'on voit pas forcément tout à l'heure
Christophe et Veuillet il est au Ferré
détail tout à fait anecdotique mais la
chanson les anarchistes dont la phrase
il y en a pas sursaut et chanté pour la
première fois le 10 mai 1968 à la
Mutualité avant que un certain nombre de
participants au concert aillent
participer à la nuit des barricades donc
vous allez lui offrir qui diffuse quand
même un certain nombre de chansons sur
les radios y compris sur les radios
nationales et puis il y a eu un autre
une autre figure centrale dans
l'anarchisme culturel c'est Georges
Brassens qui je le rappelle a été
permanent du libertaire en 1945 46 47
même et qui a des textes qui continuent
à être nourri d'une ces libertés et
cette diffusion tout à fait formelle
tout à fait dans qui passe inaperçu
finalement a beaucoup compté dans cette
génération 68 alors on a eu les groupes
des cringus trottis toutes les tous les
groupes qui seraient jamais les
ministres mais il y a l'autre aspect de
Mai 68 qui est justement tous ces
aspects tout cet aspect sociétal on
revient un peu ce qu'on disait au début
d'émission à savoir le féminisme la
révolution sexuelle ou la découverte
d'homosexualité
c'est combats sociétaux l'écologie aussi
qui dans les années 70 sont portées à la
fois ou récupérer à la fois par un
certain nombre de groupes mais sont
aussi portés par toutes que l'on appelle
les 68 ares désirant qui vont être sans
être forcément anarchiste en cartés mais
qui vont porter ces idées libertaires et
finalement il y a un triomphe entre
guillemets des idées libertaires dans le
dans la presse 68 sans que effectivement
les libertaires en tant que tel n'entir
bénéfices la propagande par le fait
c'est une mode opératoire je sais pas
comment on peut appeler les choses qui
étaient aussi citées dans le
documentaire que nous venons de faire il
se traduit par l'action armée ce qu'on
appellerait aussi le terrorisme
aujourd'hui et il se rapporte une
période de l'histoire de l'anarchisme on
pourrait dire que ça va entre
1880 au début du 20e mais alors il y a
beaucoup de victimes de cette lutte
armée mise en oeuvre par les anarchies
je vais en citer quelques-uns
assassinats de l'empereur Alexandre II
en Russie attentat contre la demeure du
conseiller Benoît président de cour
d'assises en France attentat contre la
Chambre des députés organisés par
Auguste vaillant qui donnera d'ailleurs
les lois scélérates les fameuses lois
scélérates qui ont été votées peu de
temps après assassinat du président de
la République français Sadi Carnot bien
sûr ça c'était en 1894 assassinat du
président du Conseil espagnol qui
lui-même avait fait assassiner des
anarchistes d'ailleurs à Barcelone ass
de l'impératrice ici en Autriche
assassinat du roi d'Italie Umberto
premier et enfin en 1901 assassinat du
président des États-Unis d'Amérique
William McKinley par anarchiste nommé
Léon golkose là c'est une période sombre
et c'est la lutte armée qui prévaut dans
les rois anarchistes au nom de cette
fameuse propagande par le fait on en a
fini avec cette période on associe
peut-être à tort souvent anarchisme et
violence complètement anarchiste
relativement récent dans les années 1970
c'est le groupe Action Directe Jean-Marc
Rouillon le fondateur du groupe c'est
toujours réclamé du communisme
libertaire donc il s'inscrit dans une
tradition de propagande par le fait ou
de dire d'insurrectionnalisme pour
repeindre une autre formule qu'on doit à
compotekin donc il y a quand même une
tradition alors certes aujourd'hui on
assassine plus personne heureusement les
anarchistes ceux qui militent pour les
entre cette période du début du 20ème
je pense qu'il faut bien resituer aussi
historiquement la période parce que là
on est entre en gros 1800 80 et le tout
début du 20e siècle en fait en réalité
on est plus sur une quinzaine d'années
très intense et ça fasse ça fait suite à
quoi c'est dont on parlait aux parents
c'est le massacre de la Commune de Paris
donc il y a tout le mouvement socialiste
qui a été décimé envoyé en
Nouvelle-Calédonie etc dont Louise
Michel bon et il y a un sentiment de
désespoir qui va régner chez beaucoup de
militants est-ce que la luth armée a
fait partie de la panoplie anarchiste
durant le 20e siècle Christophe boursier
évoqué
80 alors c'est assez compliqué parce que
c'est quelques individualités qui ont
décidé de passer à l'action violente
contre des personnes après vous allez
dans le coranarchiste une autre
dimension qui est également violente qui
est dire on fera la Révolution et la
révolution sera violente et puis vous
avez tout un tas d'autres militants qui
ne voulaient pas se dessaler avec
d'arriver de leur compagnons de lutte
mais qui n'étaient pas d'accord ce qui
fait qu'au moment des grands procès de
la période de la propagande par le fait
les militants qui n'étaient pas d'accord
disait bah oui on ne disait rien en fait
pour ne pas condamner les modalités
d'action même si eux en interne disait
bah non ça sert à rien ça va juste
entraîner une augmentation de la
répression et c'est pas comme ça qu'on
arrivera à faire triompher nos idées
mais on ne trouve anarchiste ni du côté
des Brigades rouges dans les années 70
ni du côté de la bande à Bader par
exemple parce que ça c'est dans toutes
les mémoires encore ça il y a
effectivement mais les Brigades rouges
comme la bande à Bader se réclame
explicitement du modèle les ministres
même dans l'action directe il y a les
les deux courants qui cohabitent quand
on prend le vocabulaire d'action
d'action directe c'est plus proche
souvent du marketing
des premiers mouvements autonomes des
années 1970 c'est une autre époque et
s'inspire de l'autonomie italienne de
l'époque qui elle passait à la lutte
armée dans cette période-là donc on a
les on a toujours eu ces
cette tentation de la violence mais dans
la majeure partie desquelles la
tentation de la violence doit être une
viande ce collective ou théorisé comme
une violence collective de vente amener
au renversement de la société c'est
l'héritage de l'héritage baconien qui
était à la fin du documentaire on n'a
pas on fait pas de révolution sans
violence mais à côté de ça vous avez
d'autres courants qui existent également
et qui disent bah non on va pas faire
comme ça du tout on va se regrouper dans
des petites communautés pour essayer
d'instituer de diffuser un condroponie
de type individualiste ou alors
troisième hypothèse enfin deux autres
éléments importants versés au départ
d'autres qui vont dire bah on va
transformer la société par le mouvement
syndical et puis un dernier paradoxe qui
est en pleine affaire Dreyfus en 1898
les premiers à défendre le service
d'ordre du futur président de la
République Émile Loubet ce sont des
militants libertaires qui sont dernière
Bernard Lazare en disant attention les
libertés alors qui vient d'avoir les
lois fédérales attention les libertés
publiques sont menacées il vaut mieux
défendre les libertés publiques
bourgeoises que de se retrouver avec des
factions au pouvoir donc il y a toujours
eu
ces multiples ambiguïtés de l'anarchisme
ou des anarchistes plutôt qui font que
c'est toujours un mouvement extrêmement
compliqué à lire ne peut pas le pluriel
on peut pas le rentrer dans une case il
faut éviter évidemment toute
stigmatisation
il y avait un courant très intéressant
il y a quelques années qui s'appelaient
anarchiste mais non violence c'était des
anarchistes grandissent qui ont publié
pendant des années une revue qui est
devenue un site web et d'ailleurs dans
le film qu'on vient de voir il est fait
allusion à plusieurs expériences de
lutte armée qui était là en gris brigade
où les toupamaros donc à le le film
reconnaît l'existence de cette
sensibilité
insurrectionnaliste qui cohabite avec
d'autres dernières questions et on se
retrouvera ensuite pour commenter le
dernier volet de cette série il est
beaucoup question de social anarchie
dans ce documentaire et il existe une
anarchie de droite j'imagine peut-être
peut-on l'appeler l'anarchie
individualisme
il n'en est pas question dans ce film
pourtant elle existe c'est un archite
droite
s'inspirent-ils il y a plusieurs
courants anarchistes de droite en fait
c'est anarchisme de droite il provient
de cette fameuse imprécision sémantique
du terme anarchiste qui fait que
beaucoup de gens disent je suis un petit
peu anar donc vous avez déjà un premier
anarchisme de droite qui est apparu au
20e siècle qui s'incarnait dans des gens
comme Michel Audiard qui était une sorte
d'anarchisme de comptoir de bistrot de
ronchon un avarchisme culturel un peu
réac dans les comptes toutes les lois
contre tout mais en fait dépassez pas
les propos de conseils
[Musique]
parfois trouble comme Céline et donc
c'était des brèves de comptoir et puis
alors vous avez un courant qui est
apparu qui venait des États-Unis qui est
apparu dans les années 1962 60 70 qui
était un courant anarcho capitaliste qui
allait au bout de l'idée que
l'anarchisme c'est la fin de l'état en
disant bah vous voyez nous les libéraux
on est pour la fin de tout état et pour
le libéralisme extrême et donc ces
anarchos capitalistes défendent encore
aujourd'hui une société de western si
vous voulez de western américain les
Ultra libéraux Elon Musk Bezos c'est
tous les grands Tycoon de la Silicon
Valley donc là on est à l'opposé de ce
que vous nous décrivez au début de cette
deuxième catégorie qui est une branche
de l'anarchisme individualisme parce que
il y a des anarchistes individualistes
qui ne veulent pas opprimer les autres
qui veulent qu'ils pensent que ils ont
droit d'avoir le royaume l'unique et sa
propriété disait sterner mais vous avez
aussi des anarchistes individualistes
qui considèrent que il faut défendre la
vertu de l'égoïsme et que de ce point de
vue là il n'en ont rien à des
autres et que ils sont pour une société
une sorte d'aristocratie libertaire qui
fait qu'il se relie à l'extrême droite
alors on reparlera peut-être de cette
anarchisme de droite
dans à l'occasion de la diffusion du
quatrième et dernier volet de cette
série ni dieu ni maître une histoire de
l'anarchisme qui a signé Tancrède
ramonais vous serez d'ailleurs ici sur
ce même plateau de débat doc à la suite
de la diffusion de ce dernier volet de
cette fresque historique consacrée à
l'anarchisme vos réactions pour
l'instant ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter merci à celle massalier qui
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission comme
à l'accoutumée rendez-vous donc pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]